[Música]
así transportaban las fuerzas de
seguridad a niños ucranianos en su
llegada a polonia son 150 huérfanos de
la región de kiev que pudieron ser
evacuados en la madrugada del martes a
ninguno le faltaba su peluche en un
traslado iniciativa de la ong happy kids
que ya ha evacuado a dos mil huérfanos
es una labor compleja hace sólo dos días
tuvimos un transporte de 700 niños y ya
saben que no es fácil encontrar un lugar
para uno pero es aún más difícil
encontrarlo para 700 a la vez en los
países vecinos de ucrania se están
comprometiendo en la acogida y los niños
especialmente vulnerables a los
conflictos que esta vez sí son prioridad
en hungría en esta escuela fronteriza
también han hecho espacio para los
huérfanos la directora del orfanato de
artech está encantada por el
recibimiento premio de los dos dejarlo
recibimos una bienvenida muy cálida en
tiempos de paz jamás nos habían recibido
así en ningún lugar encontramos mucha
ayuda humanitaria víveres zapatos ropa
papelería juguetes para niños artículos
para el hogar y nos pudimos alimentar
muy bien
una solidaridad con los más pequeños que
se extiende por toda europa casas en el
centro de francia llegó a anastasia con
sus hijos allí vive su hermana mariana
en una solución que esperan sea temporal
hace una semana que están aquí y sueñan
con volver con reencontrarse con su
padre tan pronto como termine la guerra
se irán a casa
mi hermana me dijo tan pronto como mi
marido diga que puedo las maletas
y volveremos
los vecinos de sachets se unieron al
homenaje para esta familia mientras las
naciones unidas ya reportan que más de
dos millones de personas han salido de
ucrania